we're asked to determine a function of
the form y equals a sine of BX or Y is
equal to a cosine BX represented by the
graph below so we need to figure out
maybe what the A's are what the B's are
whether this is a sine or a cosine
function so let's see what clues there
are so the first thing that I notice is
that whatever this function is when X is
equal to zero it does not equal zero it
is equal to negative two so based on
that do you think based on what we know
about sine and cosine functions do you
think that this is going to be of the
form Y is equal to a sine of the X or of
the form Y is equal to a cosine of BX
without even knowing what the A's and
B's are do you think this is going to be
a sine function or a cosine function
well let's think about what sine of zero
is if you take sine of zero we already
know that that is equal to zero what is
cosine of zero cosine of zero is equal
to one so it would be very hard and
especially in this form it would be
impossible if sine of zero is zero to
multiply sine of multiplies zero by
something to get to negative two so it
can't be it can't be a sine function of
this form you might say well the cosine
of zero is one
cosine of zero is one but here it's
negative two but at least if you have a
one you can then multiply it by
something to get to a negative two so
what we now know is that we are at least
of this form but now we have to figure
out what the A's and B's are going to be
equal to we know that this function is y
is equal to a cosine a cosine of BX so
the first the next question I ask you is
what is what is a what is a going to be
well let's think about it we already saw
if we had just cosine of zero if we just
had cosine of BX what X is equal to zero
of B times zero would just be cosine of
zero and it would get us to one but
we're not at one we're at negative two
it looks like it you took a cosine
function at least and when X is equal to
zero we multiplied it by negative two so
this should be negative two so now we
have a little bit more filled in of what
we actually have we know that it's y is
equal to negative two cosine cosine of
cosine of BX and this this gels what we
see right over here the amplitude here
you see that the difference between the
maximum value and the minimum value or
the minimum of the maximum is 4 half of
that is 2 or another way you think about
it we're varying 2 from this center
point and over here if you look think
about the amplitude the amplitude is the
absolute value of this number right over
here the amplitude is equal to the
absolute value of this negative 2 which
is indeed equal to so it's consistent so
far now let's think about what B here is
and maybe we can use our knowledge of
period of what the period of a periodic
function is to think about what B might
be well let's look over here what is the
period what is the period of this
periodic function well let's draw one
period so if we start if we use this as
our starting point we view this as our
start or one cycle I should say let's
draw one cycle if you view that as our
starting point at 2 PI over 3 we have
completed that cycle and then we can
start the next cycle we repeat the
pattern over again then you start the
next cycle so based on that what is the
period well it's the length that you
need to go a next or complete one cycle
so that length right over there you see
is 2 PI over 3 so the period the period
is 2 PI over 3 and given that given that
the period here is 2 PI over 3 can you
figure out what B is going to be well
the period of this is going to be equal
to
you is going to be equal to two PI over
the absolute value over the absolute
value of B and you can solve this
multiple ways you can multiply both
sides by three and the absolute value of
B and you will be left with the absolute
value of B is equal to is equal to three
which means that B could be equal to
positive or negative three and so you
might say well Sal what do I use does B
equal positive 3 or negative 3 and so
the next question I'll ask you is for a
cosine function so for a cosine function
do you get different values is do you
get different values of if you were to
make it this a cosine of 3x or a cosine
or a cosine cosine of negative negative
3x do you get different values well if
you play with the unit circle a little
bit if you play with the unit circle if
you play with the unit circle so I'm
going to draw a little rough unit circle
right over here remember cosine is the
x-coordinate where we intersect the unit
circle and if we go in the positive
angle direction if we go in that
direction or x-coordinate it starts at
one and then it gets a little bit
shorter if we go in the negative
direction it starts at one and then it
gets a little bit shorter and so you can
experiment this with a good bit but
you'll see that cosine of 3x and this is
only the case for cosine not for sine
cosine of 3x is equal to cosine of
negative 3x so you can actually pick
either positive 3 or negative 3 but for
simplicity in this case right over here
I'll just go with the positive 3 so this
could be the graph of now we get our
drum roll Y is equal to negative 2 times
the cosine of no I said I wouldn't do
the negative the cosine of positive 3x
and we are done